Je suis une femme noire vivant en Amérique et
il se passe beaucoup de choses en Amérique
[Musique]
bonjour, je m'appelle Asia Naomi King et je
suis une porte-parole de L'Oréal Paris ici pour
fouler le tapis rouge chez Ken
[Musique]
Je n'oublierai jamais  ma première fois
sur le tapis rouge, juste l'énergie,
les lumières et l'excitation et
il y a juste quelque chose qui est
vraiment inoubliable
[Musique]
Je suis une femme noire vivant en Amérique et
il se passe beaucoup de choses en Amérique qui le font
j'ai l'impression d'être une attaque contre les femmes noires,
de la parité des sexes au
harcèlement sexuel, honnêtement, il y a
trop de choses à compter et je suis passionné par
tout cela parce que cela a un impact sur la façon dont je vis
ma vie, cela a un impact sur la façon dont mon
enfant vivra  sa vie
[Musique] et
bien par exemple quand j'étais petit,
je n'ai jamais vu un médecin noir ou un
dentiste noir jusqu'à ce que j'en voie un à la télé donc c'est
comme si c'était une chose vraiment bizarre pour les
autres qui grandissent en voyant des gens
qui leur ressemblent  ces
positions et ces expériences
les normalisent, mais si vous ne le voyez pas,
il est plus difficile de vous permettre de
croire que cela est possible pour vous, c'est
pourquoi ce type d'inclusivité et de
représentation est vraiment important
car cela vous permet, cela vous donne la
permission.  croire que vous pouvez
y parvenir par vous-même
[Musique]
tant de femmes
J'ai eu beaucoup de chance Je veux dire, le plus
important, je dois commencer par ma
mère bien sûr, de la même manière qu'elle
m'a élevé, moi et mes sœurs, comme elle
nous a toujours donné le pouvoir de le faire  rechercher les choses qui nous
intéressaient et être curieux
du monde qui nous entoure, puis pour
moi, en grandissant, regarder des femmes comme Angela
Bassett et bien sûr Violet Davis, vous
savez, a toujours été vraiment très
important pour moi de devenir
qui je suis aujourd'hui.